you
2005 Cassini captures an astonishing
sight a hundred geysers shooting ice
particles miles into space from cracks
in the South Pole and Sela dhis is
hurtling its guts into space at a
colossal rate as in celle discord batons
feed a vast shimmering halo around the
planet
the mysterious earring
this icy plume also interacts with
Saturn's magnetic field causing a plasma
cloud of charged particles
the particles race along Saturn's
magnetic field lines and slam into
Saturn's polar atmosphere raising huge
ultraviolet Aurora's
Geysers explained the earring but how
can they exist on a frozen moon a
billion miles from the Sun on earth
geysers form in highly volcanic places
where water comes into contact with hot
rocks and Seles so small and so far from
the Sun should be cold and dead but
thanks to Saturn's gravity it's not the
source of the heating on Enceladus is
the eccentric orbit of that moon
sometimes it's a little closer to Saturn
sometimes it's a little further away and
that heating on Enceladus from that
kneading gravitationally making the
moons stretch and pull is what warms the
interior causing the activity on
Enceladus that we see today the
gravitational pull of Saturn reaches
deep into Enceladus beyond its water ice
exterior gripping its rocky core
as Saturn's grasp strengthens and
weakens it massages this cold rocky
heart bringing it to geological life
with frictional heat the heat melts the
ice around it creating a vast subsurface
Lake at the southern pole of Enceladus
this water jets out through huge cracks
in the surface ice on earth where
there's liquid water there's life could
Enceladus have what it takes for simple
organisms to exist